everyone uh it's my pleasure to
introduce paul hand who will tell us
about signal recovery with generative
fires
thank you so much for the invitation to
speak
i know there was a talk earlier today by
bruno on a very similar topic so
hopefully i'll be able to share some
other perspectives on on uh similar
questions i'll try to make this talk as
self-contained as possible since i know
the video of this is is going online
and so here we'll talk about signal
recovery from generative priors just to
set the stage the the idea here is you
have an image let's call it x naught you
have some measurements of that image
let's call those five x naught and
depending on the actual applied problem
of interest you might have a different
structure of five so you might want to
solve denoising where phi is really like
the identity plus noise or you might
want to inpaint missing pixels where phi
is really just a subsampling of the
image
or do super resolution or compress
sensing or in this talk i'll focus a lot
on phase retrieval
and so there
uh the the problem is to recover x
naught from phaseless linear
measurements uh of it
right so
uh i i want to do the the quick reminder
of what the story was for sort of like
playing compressed sensing because this
is going to set the stage for the sort
of result this is the sort of like
rigorous result we want to prove when we
talk about uh generative modeling but
let's remember that uh so there's this
standard prior for modeling images which
is sparsity prior so in a particularly
chosen basis an image might be modeled
as having relatively few non-zero
coefficients right and so if we talk
those coefficients into the vector x we
might want to find the coefficients x
such that the measurements of those
coefficients are what we observed and
here this problem uh is isn't hard and
so there's a standard convex relaxation
to instead of minimizing uh what's
called the l0 norm the number of
non-zero coefficients we'll minimize the
l1 norm right so this this led to sort
of a very significant like mathematical
advance
where uh from like candace ronberg and
tao and also david donahoe studying the
case of say a a k sparse vector the
question is how many measurements do you
need to recover that k-sparse vector uh
if your measurements are random and you
have like k log n of them where n is the
dimension of your ambient space then you
can solve this linear program um
in order to find them right so this is
this the celebrated result that like
with high probability under a random
measurement
random linear measurement model you can
recover
in essence a k-dimensional signal from
uh roughly k measurements all right so i
i
sort of i put this on the screen because
this is the sort of result that we're
going to want to mirror uh when we talk
about uh generative models
right um so there's a challenge with
this view so like i said this this the
sparsity perspective is very celebrated
it you know
in the case of linear measurements
allowed for recovery at the sample
complexity that you would expect right
proportional to the sparsity of the
signal right but unfortunately this this
doesn't appear to be working in the case
of certain non-linear problems right so
the the non-linear problem i want to
focus on is this compressive phase
retrieval problem and here the problem
is as follows where you have some signal
x naught you have a matrix a a is
compressive so it has
fewer rows than columns
and you're given an absolute value of ax
naught
from that you're trying to find x naught
and you're trying to impose this
sparsity prior right so m should be more
than k or more than s if it's an s bar
system
and you're trying to recover the signal
so the the problem here is that this is
an open problem still that there's
there's no known efficient algorithm to
recover an s sparse x naught from uh
order of s uh generic measurements
now i have to remind us that like by by
generic right that this is this means uh
essentially like uh random
right so if you have non-generic
measurements if you like cook up this
matrix a to have this exact structure
that factors in a particular way then
you can indeed get optimal sample
complexity
for solving compressive phase retrieval
in that case but in the generic case
where these measurements are not really
structured to make your life easy then
this problem is is still hard
right so this
and this problem has been attacked by
many many uh very smart mathematicians
and the perspective of this talk is
going to say to like to back up for a
second
right so compressive phase retrieval is
the task that you know one might be
interested in application and what that
means is like you're like you're a
scientist you're imaging some some
signal like maybe a protein or something
you believe that that protein is low
dimensional in a certain way
how can you take only as many
measurements as the complexity of that
like model that you have
right so there's there's no reason why
this has to be sparsity right it just
happens that images uh happen to be
frequently modeled as sparse in
particular bases which are chosen by
people
so if we can pull the people out of the
loop if we can start looking at this
from like a data driven perspective
then perhaps we can do better
so in essence what's happening is we're
saying like here is this hard problem
but the hard problem isn't actually what
we want to solve in practice so let's
let's find a different approach to
sidestep the hardness right and so that
approach um you know we'll talk about in
a minute
but what i want to uh to also point out
is that in some cases you can even like
prove that you can't use standard
techniques uh to to get sparsity to work
right so so here this is an example of a
of a convex program uh something this
would be called sparse phase lift so the
idea of phase lift is you have these uh
phaseless measurements of a signal if
you lift those to be measurements of a
matrix they become linear measurements
and so then you're looking for a low
rank matrix given the measurements that
you have and so if you you you could
envision that you could impose a
sparsity prior on that matrix that's the
matrix's coefficients
and then try to recover the matrix and
then do a a factorization of that matrix
and unfortunately like xiao dong li and
vlad vorninsky uh proved a while ago
that like problems of this form like
provably cannot work at finding an
optimal
at finding the sparse signal at optimal
sample complexity
right so here we have the setup there's
no known algorithm and for some very
natural types of algorithms you can
prove that they don't work right so this
is why we're we're sort of sidestepping
this approach all right so so that side
stepping comes from like recent
data-driven advances from the fields of
of artificial intelligence and
particular deep learning uh this was on
the front page of the new york times uh
in 2018 uh and so here this is you know
their ai-based algorithms that can be
shown a large data set of natural images
they can in essence learn the
distribution that that data set came
from in order to sample from it and so
that is what a generative model is and
they've been trained for all sorts of
applications uh and for example they can
give you like high resolution
photorealistic images of human faces uh
you could also train them in biological
cells mri images you name it
um
all right so like the the mathematical
structure of these are actually like
quite varied it's hard to put them all
in a bin but some of them have the
flavor of uh
of a mapping that is learned so here
you're you're given samples in let's say
rn so these are like images and is the
number of pixels essentially and you're
assuming that those are coming from some
probability distribution which you don't
know in advance and your goal is to
learn these right so you're going to
model this distribution as the push
forward of a simple distribution under a
learned function
so that simple distribution might we
might say this is a z it follows a
standard gaussian in k-dimensional space
you have some map g
which uh maps k-dimensional space to
n-dimensional space and here k could be
less than n k could be equal to n
and there are successful examples of
both of these
right so just to give you an example
like what does this look like visually
like here you might have say like this
latent space on the right that's that k
dimensional space the image you should
think of the data spaces that's like
image space so each of these like blue
points on the left those are like
separate images
right and so then your distribution
might be multimodal right you might have
like cats and you might have dogs and
then in the set of images there might be
some complicated geometry between them
so here you might uh sample a z that's
random like one of these red pixels down
here push it through this function you
get a new uh a new image that's from
that distribution
and so that is if everything goes well
in the training of your generative model
right so now
supposing that you have these models
right how do you use them in practice
well first you need to train them right
so this is a question for computer
scientists right how what architecture
do you use like what sort of neural
network do you use
um
if you're even using uh well i know
lightly and so then here you're going to
learn this neural net which is going to
perhaps take random noise as input and
output new samples from this
distribution maybe this distribution of
images of flowers
so once you have that g
then you can give that to the
practitioner and they're going to have
some measurements they're going to have
some measurements which is presumed to
be like phi of x naught for some unknown
x naught and then you can write down
just a straightforward minimization
problem find the find this latent code z
such that g of z
when applied under the measurements phi
agrees with the measurements that you
have and this problem you could solve
for example using gradient descent right
so in a sense this is sort of the most
immediate thing you would try with the
most immediate method uh and you know
the field of deep learning is full of
you know all sorts of tips and tricks
for like how to train these models how
to do that optimization maybe you're not
using exactly gradient descent maybe
you're using fancy variations of it
but you can use ideas of that flavor
and so then you can use these to do
compress sensing this this result uh
was uh famously um
studied by um
this borah jalal price and demarcus
paper out a ut
and here their approach for compressed
sensing was right take this g which is
trained you have some image x naught
which is either in the range of g or
near the range of g you have
measurements a of x naught if you can go
find the z naught that corresponds to
that then you have essentially found
your image you can push that back
forward through g you get uh an estimate
of your image
and so then they studied this
optimization problem
right and so they so they showed that
this you know can succeed with
significantly fewer measurements than uh
sparsity-based approaches
uh and they introduced some theory that
showed that if you can solve this
optimization problem then
under certain conditions then you can
recover the image that you're looking
for or an estimate of it with on the
order of k measurements
right
so what what i'm going to talk about and
what i'm talking about in this in this
talk is is the phase retrieval problem
and so just to compare this this is the
same as what we just saw in the last
slide but where you have these like
absolute value or of a of x not as the
measurements and so then that modifies
this optimization problem in sort of an
immediate way
now a comment like it's not trivial to
just write down that formulation you can
envision squaring the terms inside or
something like that and you actually get
different artifacts and
uh and sort of a different method that
has uh that might be easier or harder to
analyze
all right so i want to show like a
picture of you know what's what's really
going on here because this is also going
to allow us to compare these methods to
sparsity-based methods all right so
let's think i have the set of all images
that's like the ambient space here
then i might have
the
set of natural images and that will be
some low dimensional manifold in a space
but then i might have a further subset
of natural images of a particular class
that i'm interested in for example mri
images
right and so then that might be
represented by say like this red curve
or in this case it's sort of a picture
of a train
right and so then here you're given
measurements of your signals so that is
to say there's some like in the linear
case there's some like affine space that
you that you're on so the question is
where does this intersect this manifold
does it intersect it at like exactly one
point and if so then that's your signal
estimate
okay
um so like already this picture shows a
a potential improvement of these
degenerative models over sparsity-based
thinking
and that is the the dimensionality of
your natural signal class like really
comes into play
right so here if we think of this image
right and sort of like the obvious like
neighbors of this image like here's one
train going down this track right how
complex is this set
and it would be natural to model that
set as one dimensional right it's just
where along that train where along those
tracks is that train
so if i was able to you know train a
function
which took r1 to the like to that set of
images
right then i should expect to be able to
recover any particular image in that set
with one measurement
however if i take like a wavelet
perspective where i say like oh well
this is a complicated image i'm going to
represent it and wave the basis and
study which coefficients are non-zero
then i'm going to have many many more
than one
you know of one measurements that are
non-zero
right so this shows a potential benefit
which is that when you have a signal
class which is itself relatively low
dimensional that class could be lower
dimensional than the representation in
this particular wavelet basis or fourier
basis right so that's one source of a
way to improve over like sparsity-based
uh approaches
so but this is i mean i want to get to
some into one of our like rigorous
results of this since this is a more
theoretically inclined group
all right and so the my my my comment is
right the random these generative priors
do allow for rigorous recovery
guarantees
at optimal sample complexity in k
so let's i want to think about this this
model briefly right so this this is
meant to be a model of a gan a
generative adversarial network which in
this case is taking a low dimensional
input into a high dimensional output
and that you know that is only one type
of generative model that exists out in
the world sometimes k equals n and then
it's a very different story uh but this
this again is going to be modeled as a
feed forward fully connected neural
network with no bias terms
which is represented in this form where
you take you take your input z remember
that's low dimensional you hit it with
some dense matrix w1 that increases the
dimension uh then you hit that with a
rectified linear unit what that means is
you take the positive part and you kill
any negative parts component wise and
then you just have many layers of this
uh operation where you have a linear
operation and then a non-linear
activation function applied to it this
is morally speaking the essence of you
know what a neural network is
without what are called bias terms um
and so so we're going to study like we
want to
study a model of this so that we can
make solid claims and that model is
going to be we're going to assume that
at each layer there are more neurons
than in the previous layer so that is to
say there's an expansivity condition
like ni is bigger than ni minus 1.
in our work that we're going to assume
that's bigger than some constant times
ni minus 1 with a log factor
so we're also going to assume that the
the values of these weights and the
values of the measurement matrix at the
end are all gaussian right so this
really is just a an assumption for like
initial theoretical convenience but
there are some like
reasonable motivations for why it would
make sense
right so when you train a neural network
you initially start at like random
weights and then you optimize them to
fit the data set that you're training
them on now it turns out that in a
highly over parametrized regime there
are certain cases where the weights
don't actually change that much and so
then what the initially random weights
are often
you know close to being random
at the end of the training process right
so and this is part of the state of like
the theoretical understanding of when
can neural nets even be trained right um
and there are also other studies that
show that if you look at the statistics
of certain trained nets then you get
very uh gaussian-like behavior in them
right so anyway there's there's reasons
to to model it this way um and uh you
know it it does allow us to make sort of
like a rigorous claim right so this is a
a theorem that that we introduced so
with my graduate student oscar leong
who's now going to be a postdoc at cal
tech this fall uh and then with vlad
vorninsky who is the ceo of a
self-driving car startup called helm
and what we showed was that
this generative model right this random
model of a
of a generative model allows for signal
recovery from non-linear compressive uh
phaseless measurements at optimal sample
complexity so that is to say if the
number of measurements scales like k
where i'm ignoring all the log factors
dependence on d and various other things
various other terms in the problem
if the network layers are sufficiently
expensive and if everything the problem
is gaussian so the weights the
measurement matrices et cetera
then this function actually has like a
very a very nice landscape that can be
optimized yeah is there a question
is the network itself so the question is
is the network itself given in this case
yes so the network is modeled to be a
sample from just a
a sample of gaussians in all of the
entries of
the weight matrices w and the sensing
matrix
and then you're saying that is now fixed
and handed to you that's given to the
algorithm yeah so that's given to the
algorithm as it would be in practice
i mean i'm unclear if it would be
environments in the sense that you're
assuming that it would be learned
to hide your factors right so in
practice you would take you so that you
you would take data you would train a
generative model g then you would hand
that g to someone who's doing the
inverse problem and for the person who's
doing the inverse problem that g is
fixed
right so here the theory
is i mean this actually this gets like a
very deep question right
like we don't know and i'm not sure
anyone knows like how to mathematically
describe like natural data
right so like all of the theoretical
results in this area are going to have
the form where they they sidestep the
question of what does natural data
really look like and they're going to
say okay assuming the structure of what
it could be then here's the the result
that we have
right so here we're assuming for the
inversion g is fixed we're assuming it
was handed to you as the outcome of just
a random process
and then for the inversion that g that
that g is the g
so now the model for what in natural
images is something that's near the
range of that random function
so so here the
the the comment is the this
the the optimization problem that we
wrote down on the previous slide
actually is relatively nice in this in
this situation it's not convex like as
you can see but it has uh
so a very nice structure that if you run
gradient descent down it um maybe you
get stuck at this left well but uh but
the global minimum is at the right well
this is really the plot versus the
latent dimension of the latent variable
z
in the case of dimensionality equals two
uh and so there's uh there's some tricks
you can do to make sure that you don't
get stuck in this spurious minimum so so
we showed that this function is like
able to be optimized and in fact there's
uh so follow-up work to this that that
we proved that gradient descent with a
minor twist can actually provably
converge to the global minimum here
all right
uh so so i i mean i'm running a little
low on time but i just want to quickly
comment that sort of the the bread and
butter of this
of this proof is based on like
discontinuous matrix-valued random
functions
right and so here there you want to
study matrices that have this form like
you have like random vectors wi so you
want to study like w i w i transpose so
something like this short matrix
but remember that the the neural net
itself had these rayleigh activation
functions so they kept positive terms
and uh you know sort of zeroed out
negative terms so here this visceral
matrix is going to be
um have these extra terms where there's
like an indicator function for whether
this this uh random direction wi is
aligned with some direction y or some
direction x and we want to study this as
a function of x and y right so this is a
discontinuous function of w it's a
random object and we want to show that
it concentrates toward its expectation
and so we can prove things like this you
know with with high probability then um
if like this matrix is like taller than
it is wide by like uh n log n factor uh
then we can get this concentration
so result this result has actually been
improved by um by others
but it illustrates that the type of
mathematics that's underlying this like
non-asymptotic results
so uh
the the this result works in some like
practical situations where you can like
train a generative model in this case on
uh digits and then with many fewer
digits uh you can recover the digits uh
somewhat accurately relative to these
sparsity-based approaches so this this
second row is this deep phase retrieval
approach with something called the
variational autoencoders the generative
model uh and it was able to succeed
where all these uh where this say sparta
sparsity-based method uh did not
um
and so i i want to
sort of get to this list that's that
qualitative point right so this is a
plot of like reconstruction error versus
number of measurements for phase
retrieval under a variety of signal
priors uh so this blue curve is is our
work we're using generative models
this uh and these other approaches are
like other like sparsity-based
approaches for
um
uh four phase retrieval and so what we
see is that at the low measurement
regime like we can get significantly
less reconstruction error than the
sparsity-based approaches but at the
high measurement regime like the
performance of these generative models
often bottoms out
and and then the sparsity-based models
can can perform well in those regimes
and i want to just sort of like visually
reveal why this is the case
right so you could say like i'm going to
give you a bunch of faces
and i'm going to train a generative
model of those faces so maybe i give you
celebrity faces there's a standard data
set called celebe from which you can
train a generative model and then i'm
going to take non-celebrities and i put
them through
ask like what is the closest function in
the range of my generative model to
those faces
uh and here these faces on the top you
know get turned into these faces on the
bottom and you can see they're
significant errors that happen for
example like this older woman becomes a
younger one because the training data
set like is biased toward uh youth
uh and there are other biases you know
away from glasses and beards their
biases and toward various skin tones etc
you can take this to
well so the comment is these can have
like significant representation errors
like they might not be able to represent
your signal or you trained it on some
data that data might not be close to
what you're testing it on uh we can take
this to like an extreme we remember we
train this model on faces let's start
giving it progressively less face like
things you know like this chimpanzee and
then it's going to round it to perhaps
the nearest human which is someone whose
eye sockets are exactly the same or
whose glasses are exactly the same the
size of the eyes of that chimpanzee and
you can see how in a sense
this gender model is doing what we asked
it to do right it learned what humans
are we gave it something it gave us the
closest thing toward what we got uh even
here like this door gets turned into a
face or this butterfly gets turned into
a face
okay so you can indeed have very poor
out of distribution performance and this
is a problem because when you're
thinking about you know why are we doing
all this right we're building systems so
that we can image things maybe we're
imaging like new medical pathologies or
something
um so those are precisely going to be
things in some cases that we have not
seen before and they're going to be out
of distribution right so this this this
failure of being able to handle things
around out of distribution is a
significant issue and it's something
that there's been a lot of work in the
field uh about uh so this really is just
in essence the background to then point
out that there's now been significant
follow-up and a variety of approaches
for how you handle the representation
error of these generative models
all right so just to kind of tie the
sort of some some big ideas from the
stock
so so generative priors can in some
cases be optimally exploited for
nonlinear problems right so that means
if i have a generative model that
describes my system as a k dimensional
manifold then i should only have to pay
k measurements in order to recover a
point on that manifold
right so this is this is this is good
so further the added benefit is that
it's possible that the dimensionality of
that manifold is less than what it would
be had you use sparsity price
right so even if we could optimize
optimize sparsity linearly
it could still be worse than generative
modeling
so the the tradeoff here is you get a
low dimensional non-convex optimization
problem instead of a high dimensional
convex program
and then and then this this last comment
you know that in some cases generative
priors can empirically outperform
sparsity priors for a variety of
problems
i want to like
end on this sort of a little bit as a
reflection and a little bit as a word of
caution right
so
generative models like as you've seen
have some of these like very nice
properties right we can exploit them
optimally
like we saw before
but there are issues right let's
remember a general model didn't just
appear from the sky right it was trained
on data so if you're solving a problem
with a very specific
domain where you don't have a lot of
data then a generative model might not
be for you
right now there are fields of machine
learning such as transfer learning where
maybe you can train elsewhere and
fine-tune in your domain and the tricks
you can do right but that's one uh point
the other point is that there are
entirely other approaches which don't
require any training data whatsoever and
are based on neural networks and so
these are things like something called
the deep image fire and the deep decoder
where like
you have zero training data you're
exploiting some of the bias of neural
networks itself
to help you recover images and those
methods work surprisingly well given
that they have no training data right so
so one should not rush to solve problems
with generative modeling but there are
many cases where general modeling have
showed a
very nice performance in practical
applications
all right uh and with that here's some
some references one thing i do want to
point out is we are running a workshop
at nurips this winter on deep learning
and inverse problems and so if you're
interested in uh attending that or
submitting a paper to that um i
encourage you to look it up all right
thank you
any questions
the navy send you an instagram
so it sounded uh like just earlier the
last claim was that the this like floor
in the error
of uh
this recovery using a generative uh
prior i guess was because of kind of a
mismatch between the generative model
and what you're testing on is that right
well i i would say that in that
particular case it is because there you
might be using a general model with a
finite dimensional representation of the
data
right so you know you'll be an image
space and you say like i'm modeling
bases is 200 dimensional
what but like faces might actually be
250 dimensions and so now there's 50
dimensions you're not covering
right and so that's going to mean that
you're you're just not going to be able
to model those dimensions
so these approaches that are working
that don't have a significant of a
representation error problem are ones
which might say maintain a probability
density over all possible images and
then they allow you to like gracefully
have a tale of
um you know like of like how natural
things are
so it really goes back to like the the
the choice the structure that you use
for your generative model
like can cause problems
uh and uh the more recent methods are
ones that are much higher dimensional in
representation
now the problem with not introduces now
theoretical problem right the the
ultimately all of this theory that
that that i showed
that i showed today says if you have a k
dimensional manifold you need k
measurements to find a point
right but in practice people aren't
using low k dimensional manifolds
anymore people are using high
dimensional manifolds sometimes with
more parameters than the entire
dimensionality of the problem you have
so now this theory just doesn't apply
and so that's sort of a very
it's a theoretically very motivating uh
issue based on what's going on in
practice
but sorry just to follow why don't we
see the same phenomenon in the sparse uh
kind of variants of it like it shouldn't
there be something similar where you
know the true
images or whatever aren't sparse in the
way of the basis or something and
therefore we should also see some
baseline well and i mean so they're
always like parameters that are tuned
uh and so then you can i like in a case
where like if i say i give you like all
of the pixels of the image
right and i say like find the sparsest
thing that's consistent with that
well as a singleton
right whereas in the generative model
case you could say find me the point in
the range of the generative model that's
closest to that now you have an error
okay great
well let's fall again
[Music]
thanks